No cara Lascia perdere che già non ne
posso più di questo Natale non vedo
l'ora che finisca che poi sento gente
che fa mille cene mille pranzi aperitivi
ue ma cioè ma il 25 a pranzo e basta che
poi già le sento tutte che si lamentano
che sgrassano [ __ ] ma voglio dire Ma se
ti trasforma in un bidone dell'umido
durante le feste ovvio che grazie No ma
guarda guarda si devono fare gli auguri
e bloccano tutto il traffico ma te parlo
normale ma siete proprio pirla eh
quest'anno vengono proprio tutti tutti
tutti tutti i cugini della Germania
quelli della Francia addirittura vengono
dall'Australia Calcola che dal 10 che
cucino e congelo teglia per forza perché
se ci sediamo il 24 ci rialziamo il 6
qualcosa di pronto ce lo devo pure avere
Ti devo raccontare la signora di sopra
Cioè il figlio che studia a Milano
niente ieri l'ha chiamata e gli ha detto
che non viene a Natale fai schifo quella
piangerà da due giorni c'ho detto guarda
che non è un problema Aggiungo un posto
a tavola che c'è un'amica in più a
proposito devo andare perché devo
iniziare a farlo sfincione dieta dieta e
feste non possono stare la stessa frase
o no E poi se ti togli pure il piacere
del mangiare che